Hello Freak bitches,
but you can't be a gay woman.
You're also a lesbian.
Like a gay man is not a thing.
Like he doesn't have an extra thing.
It's not like you're also a lesbian,
you know,
you're.
You know what I mean?
Now you're talking to Tom Cruise.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
lesbians are not just gay.
They have their own little designation.
That's how they want it.
They get what they want.
This I was reading,
I was reading those.
Joey,
I was reading those like the terms now.
CISGENDER.
Oh yeah,
those are wonderful.
I ran out.
I ran out of printing paper.
I'm not.
Shit I was spitting out was.
I was on like page 78.
I ran out of paper and I just started reading them.
I actually do this in my special,
my CSO special that's coming out Thursday.
I talking about the.
I got so confusing now.
The libs,
you confuse every and nobody knows what bathroom to use and I got that a
nightclub the other night and here's the ladies room right here.
And the men's room was right.
Next one's a pile of shit in the middle
with a Tampon.
Stuck it in a fake mustache.
It's true,
and I'm not being derogatory.
I actually have a relative who was transgender.
I wouldn't want to fucking help,
you know,
but,
but we're talking about these people,
like they make up 60 percent of the population.
That's where I get a little fucking angry.
Who's that guy from roadhouse being the guy with the mustache that talks like
this,
you know,
that guy was always in like Sam Elliot,
Sam Elliot,
yes.
There's a great meme with Sam Elliott and it was like they used to be a time
when we worried more about the safety of women and children than men who like to
wear dresses.
It was one of those memes online,
like holy shit.
And someone put it up and everybody went crazy because here's the thing,
like there are people who are fucking crazy,
who are men who like to wear dresses,
want to pretend they're a woman.
There's transgender people and then they're sick fucks that also likes to wear
dresses and go into the women's room.
Opened the door.
You opened the door to everybody.
Well,
that's what I said to these young kids and I'm onstage like these kids in their
twenties like,
well you should be taken advantage of this confusion.
You had a nightclub.
You see a hot chick.
You just slap it on.
Follow her into the ladies room and go.
I identify as a dyke tonight.
Open that stall.
I'm laying any linux.
Went back when she used to wear suits.
But I'm definitely a woman.
When Eddie Linux used to wear suits.
Yes.
Sweet dreams.
Um,
I don't remember when,
when,
when.
That was big.
When we looking at it going,
whoa,
what will be good in a suit?
He's hot shit.
Everything beautiful.
She was so.
Did she come up with.
She is.
No,
she's a woman.
She's a woman.
She,
she actually looks good there for Christ with orange hair.
That looks like if trump was transgender teens
as teens.
Like what?
He's like 11.
It looks like the president.
What a weird haircut.
The ability to get that.
Oh Jesus had he can do that shit.
I can't put my leg.
This guy look at this shit.
Well,
I just took a triangle themselves like that.
That freaky.
That's pretty.
Pretty cold.
Come on Bro.
That's freaky.
That guy's oldest.
Fuck.
He know why he's doing this because he's thinking about how much dick.
He's to swing at this video's done.
He was doing the shit when he was second warmed up.
I'm going to fuck like this.
Let me show you.
I get
up like my dick is my leg.
I think he's still alive,
but he was doing it at 75 he was doing because he was on his album.
My ass pose
doubled.
Triangle suck my cock and he is not alive to.
He's never going to die at 70 6:40.
He's holding his weight.
He's 100 years old here.
Did his assets deteriorate and going?
Wow.
That's amazing.
He's 30 years old in this video.
Look at this fucking spinal flexibility though.
That is incredible.
I don't fuck with me younger when I just say that is incredible.
He honey dicked you into thinking it was no big deal.
Me On cook suitcase right there and my.
Yeah,
I can put them in a tote.
Gobble,
gobble,
gobble.
I can bring him in a tote and be like,
I brought my fucking
gobbled from my tools as well for an extra stimulation stimulation to center
global Chinese
just fine.
This is how I got from my back side.
Not just,
not a lot of spinal movement,
just gobble.
He's talking the whole time teaching.
It's just what I'm thinking of coming in my own mouth.
Maybe
not today.
Today's
not that impressed with this guy.
All right,
let's wrap up.
Alright,
so as crowder on too.
I'm glad we got through this dude.
No,
it was.
You're saying I really appreciate your generous dude and I really do like you
fucked with you a little bit.
I,
I treated you like a standup comedian.
I figured you'd fuck with me back and you got a little four.
Fine.
We got that.
We got back.
We got through it.
Yeah.
We got listen seriously.
And for those listening,
honestly I won't say I don't because I don't want you to get in trouble if I say
behind the scenes joe has done some things.
He's been very nice.
So he's a nice he,
you know.
Anyway.
I don't know if that hurts your street credit,
but like,
no,
I don't have any bad credit.
Have Zeros.
Tree.
Correct.
I like have cats.
You have cats?
I have no street cred.
Dude.
I take yoga.
He's a good dude to folks.
We're all fine.
We're going to be.
We're going to find a way.
All of these ideas to come together.
This is part of it is part of it.
The movie,
the Wrestler is one of my dad's favorite movies and we're watching that with me
and my dad loved to go watch movies again.
It's Kinda like our thing.
So we bond.
No,
I never saw that.
That was the Mickey Rourke one.
I saw like a scene from it and that was it.
I just never.
I always wanted to.
I never sat down and watched it and it's so funny.
It was like I just watched a grown man cry.
Like I watched my dad just.
Yeah.
Me and my dad can't.
I mean I love my dad to best to death,
but when we watch like father,
son movies,
anything like that,
it's always a tear jerker for them.
Oh,
me too.
I'm the same way.
Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
That's hilarious.
I couldn't watch pursuit of happiness.
Which ones?
That it was will smith and the kid.
Oh,
wouldn't it becomes homeless.
Fuck that.
Oh yeah.
I was like,
no,
no.
I was going to do that to me.
I'll tell you what you were telling.
Don't want to.
I'll give away a giant spoiler alert if I say this,
but I tried to watch that movie that we were talking about.
Uh,
the arrival or arrival,
whatever it is.
I try to get through the first year.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Shut it off.
Not Interested in anymore.
You're not going to play my heartstrings.
Spoiler alert.
You fuck the figure out the movies.
You cry during Armageddon.
Just the asteroid and.
Nope.
I knew it was fake at all.
I knew the other one was faked to deep impact.
That was fake as fuck too.
Oh yeah,
that was terrible.
Do you think that people from deep,
deep impact meet people that are fans of Armageddon?
They go,
Oh my God,
I love you from that Bruce Willis movie.
Like,
fuck you bitch.
Hey,
I was in the other one.
It came out a few months ago,
but we came out first.
We were at first armageddons bullshit.
Well he thought that Armageddon and they had the idea first.
No,
that's the propaganda.
It's fake news.
Fake News.
Bruce Willis,
man.
Yeah,
he just said I'm good.
stop.
Just chill.
Probably just go surfing and shit.
What does he do now?
She's still acting.
No,
what are you gonna say you were gonna.
Say something.
Spoiler alert.
Oh yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
I can't wait.
All right.
Keep your trap shut.
You don't want to ruin it for everybody.
Yeah,
he's always been like that guy.
There's like some dudes that get attached.
It's just really kind of fascinating when you think about how many people there
are and think how many dudes get attached to like that action movie genre.
Oh,
like Bruce Willis,
like boom,
diehard,
you know,
like he was the guy for the extraction.
Be snarky action star who figured out how to save everybody and yeah,
that first diehard man.
What was the one that won the football one with Damon Wayans right above there.
That right there,
the last boy scouts,
there was another one he did and he's always just like troubled cap,
blended pizza up with milk for breakfast.
You know what I mean?
So he's that guy smoking a cigarette.
Well,
I guess we're just gonna have to find out.
Yeah,
he was the same dude in 16 bucks.
Duties in a gang.
Movies like that.
At the same dude in a pulp fiction.
And he played that boxer dude.
He was great.
Hudson Hawke,
man.
Bruce Willis has been in some good fucking movies.
What was the one with the kid?
The Kid?
No,
the one with,
um,
that's
a movie called the kid where he's a go mercury,
right.
Oh,
$6.
Six cents.
Yeah.
He's in a lot of move with.
That movie was fucked up.
That was one movie.
It was like,
whoa.
What is this?
I think nights coming back.
I don't know about all that dude.
That village moving may be done with him.
I clean my fucking hand.
No,
I get it.
He's someone put it this way.
He's like,
m nights,
like the girlfriend,
you know better than she'd come back to know better.
Fuck her man.